مجلس محافظي الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه اجتماعا دوريا في فيينا يبحثوا
ملفات من بينها الملف النووي الايراني
وبنود اتفاق الضمانات المشتركه ياتي
الاجتماع بعده زياره مدير الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رافايا الى ايران بالتزامن
مع جوله لوزير الدفاع الامريكي في الشرق
الاوسط يجري خلالها مباحثات بشان البرنامج
النووي الايراني
في طهران اعرب المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني عن امله بان لا
يكون هناك تسييس وضغوط في اجتماع مجلس
محافظ الوكاله في فيينا وقال ان طهران
توصلت لتفهمات مع الوكاله خلال زياره غروس
الاخيره الى ايران يمكن ان تمهد لحل
القضايا العالقه بين طهران والوكاله
نشاز خضر
اجتماعه مجلس محافظي الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه الروتيني والاجتماع اليوم
لن يناقش فقط الجزئيه المتعلقه بملف
البرنامج النووي الايراني وتقرير روسي حول
زيارته الى ايران بل سيشمل ملفات اخرى
زياره جروسي الى طهران فتحت صفحه جديده في
العلاقات مع الوكاله ونتوقع ان يحافظ
اجتماع مجلس محافظي الوكاله على هويته
التقنيه والا نشهد اي تدخلات سياسيه من
جانب اعضائها وان تناقش المواضيع بعيدا عن
محاولات بعض الدول تسييس الاجتماعي وفرض
الضغوط على الوكاله
كما اكد المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه
استعداد بلاده للعوده الى المفاوضات بشان
ملفها النووي وقال ان طهران ترى ان
المسارى دبلوماسي افضل طرق لتسويه
الخلافات
الجمهوريه اسلاميه
ونرى انها افضل طريقه لتسويه الخلافات وحل
الملفات المعقده مشاركتنا في المفاوضات
النوويه التي ادت الى التوصل للاتفاق
النووي كانت بسبب التزامنا بالدبلوماسيه
لكن التفاهمات تتطلب عملا مشتركا ومتبادلا
من جميع الاطراف الموقعه على الاتفاق
مستعدون للعوده الى تنفيذ التزاماتنا في
الاتفاق النووي اذا عادت الاطراف كافه الى
التزاماتها ومن ضمنها الولايات المتحده
زياره جروسي الى طهران تمت في اطار الجهود
لفتح مسارات جديده لتسويه الملفات التقنيه
تنمو الى مراسلين من طهران مراسل الجزيره
نور الدين ومن داخل مقر الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه في فيينا مراسل جزيره محمد
البقالي محمد ابدا معك مع بدء اجتماع مجلس
محافظي الوكاله ما هو المتوقع خروجه
بصدد ملف ايران
اذا اخذنا
الخطاب الذي القاه جروسي رافاييل قروسي
مدير عام وكاله وكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه في افتتاح هذه الاجتماع والذي
تسربت بعض ما صدر فيما جاء فيه قبل دقائق
من الان يمكن ان نقول ان اتجاه العام هو
اتجاه نحو التهدئه لماذا رحب في خطابه
بمقال انها تطمنات عاليه المستوى بتعاون
ايراني مع الوكاله على مستوى الرصد
والتحقق بما في ذلك المواقع الثلاثه التي
تقول الوكاله ان ايران لم تعلن عن وجود
انشطه نوويه فيها واكتشفتها الوكاله وهذا
يشكل واحده من نقاط الخلاف الرئيسيه لان
الدول الغربيه تقول بان انشطه ايران
النوويه منذ توقف المحادثات الاتفاق
النووي اصبحت تتم بعيدا عن اعين الوكاله
وان هذا الامر قد سمح لايران بالذهاب
بعيدا في برنامجها النووي بشكل يثير مخاوف
كبيره في الغرب وهذا الامر عبرت عنه فرنسا
بريطانيا المانيا وايضا الولايات المتحده
ويمكن ان نذكر في هذا السياق حديث مساعد
وزير الدفاع الامريكي امام الكونجرس الذي
قال انه في الوقت الذي انسحبت فيه
الولايات المتحده عام 2018 من الاتفاق
النووي كان بامكان ايران ان تصنع مواد
النوويه قابله لتدخل في صنع قنبله ذريه في
اثني عشر شهرا الان اصبحت قادره على فعل
ذلك في 12 اسبوعا اي ان قدراتها قد تطورت
وهذا التطور بالنسبه للدول الغربيه تم
بعيدا عن اعين ورقابه الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه عندما ياتي جروسي امام
محافظ الوكاله ويقول انه يرحب بالنتائج
التي خرجت من الاخيره لايران والتي في
الحقيقه ينظر اليها الى انها كانت محاوله
لنزع فتيل توتر كبير بين ايران وبين
الوكاله وايضا بين مع الدول الغربيه فهذا
الامر يشير بشكل عام الى نزوع عام نحو
التهدئه لانه في العاده جرت ان الملاحظات
التي يقدمها المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
تعطي الاطار العام الذي تسير فيه
المحادثات هذا لا يعني لا يمنع ان المدير
العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه قدم
انتقادات بشان
منشات بعض المنشات النوويه وخاصه منها
منشات فوردو التي تخصب اليورانيوم بنسبه
60% وقال ان ايران قد غيرت في المنشاه
وغيرت في الاتفاق الذي كان مسبقا مع
الوكاله في اطار البروتوكول الاضافي ولكن
بشكل عام ما لمسناه من خطابه هو انه نزع
نحو التهديه واذا اخذنا هذا الخطاب واضفنا
اليه الرغبه الامريكيه المعلنه بعدم
التصعيد في هذا الاجتماع خلافا للرغبه
الاوروبيه
فهذا ربما يعطينا مؤشرا على ان الامور
تتجه نحو التهدئه افكار تهدئه اكثر وعدم
التصعيد محمد هذا الاجتماع نقرا ارتدادات
في طهران نور الدين الدغير الى اي درجه
طهران تبدو مرتاحه الى اصداء ما يقال حتى
الساعه
نعم سلمى بكل تاكيد الان ما يحدث في جنيف
فيينا هو نتاج للزياره التي قام بها غروسي
هنا الى طهران ولقائه بالمسؤولين
الايرانيين لكن بكل تاكيد هنا سلمى لابد
الوقوف عند مجموعه من التفاصيل يبدو انها
اغفلت او ربما حتى لم تفهم نوعيه التعاطي
ما بين ايران وما بين الوكاله الدوليه
وماذا حدث هنا بالضبط في طهران النقطه
الاساسيه التي يمكن الحديث عنها على ان
طهران والوكالات اسسوا ما يمكن ان نصطلح
عليه باطار للتفاهم بمعنى انهم لم يصلوا
بعد الى مرحله التفاهمات وحل الاشكالات ما
حدث هنا في طهران هو اطار للتفاهم على
اساس ان يتم الحديث في التفاصيل من خلال
اجتماع الخبراء المقرر كذلك ان يعقد قريبا
في طهران لحل الاشكالات العالقه ما بين
طهران وما بين الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه لكن بكل تاكيد هناك مجموعه من
النقاط عندها طهران ويبدو انها تحاول ان
تسكها في تعاملها مع الوكاله ويبدو كذلك
من البيان المشترك الصادر ما بين طهران
وما بين الوكاله انه تم صك هذه المعادله
بناء على ما تريد طهران كانت قبل هذا
الاجتماع الاخير مع كانت تحاسب بالاتفاق
النووي كان يتم نظرها اليها من باب
البروتوكول الاضافي الان ما تمت الاشاره
اليه على ان العلاقه ما بين ايران وما بين
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه سيكون ضمن
اتفاقيات الضمانات الشامله وليس ضمن
مخرجات الاتفاق النووي التي احدى اسوسه
البروتوكول الاضافي والسؤال الجوهري اذا
ماذا يعني ذلك على الاقل هنا الوكاله تريد
بشكل او باخر ان تكون حاضره هنا في طهران
في المواقع التي يتم التعامل معها ما بين
طهران والوكاله وهي المواقع التي تشهد
انشطه نوويه لكن بكل تاكيد الهدف الايراني
من كل هذا هناك مجموعه من النقاط الاساسيه
النقطه الاولى بان يتم التعامل مع ايران
خارج بنود الاتفاقنا ولا تحاسب على اي
اجراء نووي اتخذته او ما اصطلح عليه هنا
في ايران في اجراءات خفض الالتزامات في
الاتفاق النووي سواء من زياده نسبه
التقسيم سواء من زياده اجر الطرد المركزي
او انواع اجهزه الطرد المركزي هناك نقطه
اساسيه كذلك ومهمه ان ايران بناء على هذا
البيان هي تغلق الباب لطرح الملفات جديده
وهذا ما كان تطالبه بطهران باعتبار ان
الضمانات الشامله اتفاقيات الضمانات
الشامله تعطي الحق للدوله وليس للوكاله
الدوله مكلفه بالاعلان والوكاله ليست لها
القدره على ان تطرح ملفات جديده الا اذا
كانت تحت البروتوكول الاضافي والنقطه
الاساسيه والمهمه ان كل ما سيتم بحثه الان
مع الوكاله سواء في قضيه المناطق او
المناطق النوويه المختلف عليها سيكون كذلك
ضمن اتفاقيات الضمانات الشامله وهذا يفتح
يد ايران بدرجه الاولى كذلك وكذلك على
مستوى مستويات التقسيم اذا بكل تاكيد هناك
ارتياح ايراني مما يحدث الان في الوكاله
لكن بكل تاكيد لم تقفل الباب انه اذا تم
توفير الاجواء في الوكاله تكون طيران هنا
لانها سترد على اي توتر يستهدفها سواء في
مجلس حكام الوكلاء وعبر بيان يصدر عن مجلس
حكام الوكاله شكرا لك غير من طهران ومحمد
البقالي من المقر
الوكاله الدوليه لاطاقه الذريه في فيينا